oh my God okay the ending of this story
is crazy I kind of can't wait to get to
it because I feel like you guys are
gonna freak Bud uh yeah so we're
covering Defenders Beyond right we
basically finished Avengers versus X-Men
versus eternals now we need a new series
to start so uh here's the thing all
right let's just kind of get into this
right so what is going on here is this
takes place after the death of Stephen's
strength right if you guys remember that
story that we covered Stephen Strange is
dead in Marvel Comics and his role was
basically taken over by CLIA who was at
one point his Apprentice then she became
his girlfriend then his wife and then
they got a divorce and they've kind of
been basically Friends with Benefits
ever since and so she's like the new
Doctor Strange Stephen Strange is out
but what ends up happening here is one
of the things that Stephen Strange had
done is he had kind of left these
instances where he had kind of foreseen
these events unfolding different things
that were going to take place over the
course of the universe and kind of left
a portion of himself Beyond I mean if
we're being honest here it's a plot
device right it's one of the things you
guys are gonna notice about this uh
Story by Al Ewing he really really has
fun with it more so than anything else
which is kind of the best way to handle
this kind of stuff but what is going on
here is Stephen Strange basically visits
blue Marvel Adam Brashear and this is a
cool moment because this is something
that you don't really see all that often
right when it comes to Adam Brashear the
blue Marvel and Marvel Comics he's
always one of these characters where
he's kind of fringed to a degree you
don't see him all that often but when
you do it's usually because something's
popping off like in the Doctor Doom solo
series when Adam Brashear the blue
Marvel fights Doctor Doom and yes we are
going to cover that because that story
is amazing
it is like the best Doctor Doom story
ever but what goes on here is you
basically have Adam Brashear in his
underwater base right those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with him his base of
operations is actually down in the ocean
it kind of allows them to basically
operate in peace and he's met by what is
in effect the spirit of Stephen Strange
that basically starts presenting him
tarot cards with the intention of
basically bringing back the Defenders
now it wasn't always that way in Marvel
Comics right the idea of like the tarot
cards and the Defenders that didn't
become a thing until the 1990s the
original Defenders team was kind of a
loose knit coming together of
superheroes for a particular purpose and
that was supposed to be it it became so
popular that Marvel actually kept it as
an on running series that went on for a
long time the Defenders was immensely
popular when it was running in Marvel
now over time the series became
unpopular because basically Riders you
know different writers just kind of
screwed it up but in the 2000s Marvel
tried to bring it back and what they
gave us was Doctor Strange's secret
Defenders and so what Doctor Strange
would do is that when there was some
kind of a Calamity say for example like
dormammu was coming back or something
like that he would just start drawing
tarot cards and he would assemble a team
he was an amazing concept that was
terribly executed Doctor Strange would
assemble a team that had like Wolverine
and Spider-Man and like Cyclops and
somebody else I'm just arbitrarily
drawing names here but he would
literally just assemble a team of
characters that you would never expect
expect to see team up and they would go
face a villain that you would never
expect to see them face off against it
was great and I absolutely loved it but
the thing about this is that this is
where all that comes from and so hitting
up Adam Brashear there are a few things
that Adam Brashear takes note of for
example
eternity mask right The Eternity mask is
a really cool concept of Marvel Comics
the way this works is that the wearer of
The Eternity mask immediately has a
level of power that matches whoever
they're facing off against so if like
some random dude named Chris who's
literally just walking down the street
stumbles Across The Eternity mask he
could put it on and then if he were to
fight like World breaker Hulk he would
immediately have as much power as World
breaker Hulk has that would actually
change based on how powerful the the
world breaker Hulk becomes if he faced
off against Galactus he would
immediately be as powerful as Galactus
it really is it's kind of a McGuffin in
comics but it is cool it's a really
really interesting thing but immediately
one of the things to know is that Adam
Brashear is a man of science so when
he's met by this kind of disembodied
spear spirit in the form of an orb from
Stephen Strange that's like hey blue
Marvel I need you for a magical Mission
his immediate response is like no that's
ridiculous I'm not going off on some
magic Mission because uh because of a
mystical orb told me so but the reason
why Doctor Strange is approaching blue
Marvel is because the threat they're
dealing with doesn't necessarily exist
within the Multiverse itself it actually
exists beyond the Multiverse beyond the
Multiverse hint hint nudge nudge told
you this story was going to be amazing
so here's what goes on right so
literally what what Doctor Strange says
is because of the various things that
you faced off against right the first
Cosmos which we'll we'll cover all that
stuff as we get further on into this
because all that comes back man right
the first firmament the aspirins the
celestials it all gets Revisited here
this story is fantastic God I love this
story so much but he says like you face
off against some of the most powerful
beings in existence right Auntie man
Connor Sims who basically just like
demolished The Avengers and when I say
demolished I mean that doesn't even
begin to tell it right like literally
this guy just ko'd the Avengers like the
most powerful Avengers the century Carol
Danvers kind of which is important I
guess she doesn't really matter but like
basically like he ko'd pretty much all
the Heavy Hitters of the Avengers
anti-man was on a whole different level
and then he became the like the herald
of Galactus which amped his power up
even more the guy could enter and leave
the Multiverse at will it was crazy how
powerful Connor Sims became but like
Adam Brashears face off against some
major guys and that's why he's here
right that's why Steven strange
approaches him but again a lot of this
is is really just kind of Adam Brashear
blowing it all off and considering it to
be ridiculous until he looks back at the
deck of tarot cards and realizes a card
has been flipped over Beyond his will
meaning he didn't do it somebody did and
the card seemed to have flipped on its
own and the reality is that it basically
shows the dead body of America Chavez
now the reason why this matters is
because when Al Ewing was writing the
ultra ultimate America Chavez was on
that team if you guys never saw if you
if you never read the ultimates we
covered that I'll have the playlist down
in the description make sure you go
check that out at the end of this video
because the ultimate is phenomenal to
give you guys perspective in the first
story arc of the ultimate the team right
so like basically blue Marvel black
panther America Chavez Spectrum Monica
Rambo Carol Danvers America like they
all overpower Galactus in the first Arc
it's kinda nuts it's just it's
ridiculous it only gets more insane from
there like the molecule man comes back
who's ridiculously opius it's a
phenomenal story but the thing about
this is that you end up having him come
into this realization that there really
is more going on here which is really
crazy because America Chavez pops up
just at that point in time now one of
the things going on here is that America
Chavez's Powers aren't really what they
used to be meaning she can't really jump
through realities the way she was able
to before that was covered in America
Chavez made in the USA we're not going
to come over that because that story
sucks but uh that's basically what goes
on there right like her powers are
basically diminished and so as a result
of that she literally hits up Adam
Brashear for help and Adam Brashear
sends her away because realizing what's
going on with like these tarot cards and
magical prophecies that if America
Chavez stays with Adam Brashear she's
gonna end up dying but the truth about
this is that once the once these events
are set in motion meaning once the cards
are drawn there's no way to undo it
right like everything is going to happen
now and that's when Adam Brashear starts
looking through the cards and starts
seeing Loki he starts seeing Taya which
is kind of crazy and Loki and Taya both
show up right now Loki for the most part
is a little bit of a Nuance here we'll
explain him here in a second what's
going on with Taya is she's basically
the mother of Galactus that happened
during the events of the first Defenders
run we can cover it if you're interested
because I feel like some of you guys are
kind of like wait what the mother of
Galactus yeah like galactus's Mom right
she basically joins up with the
Defenders it's kind of interesting it's
a little wonky it's a really really cool
story we we just hadn't really covered
it for this version of Loki this is
actually a Time displaced Loki and it
goes back to the events of Secret Wars
so for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with that story before Secret
Wars actually happened when Jonathan
Hickman was writing Avengers The New
Avengers Marvel actually had a series of
other stories going at the same time
which was called last days and it was
basically here's what's going on with
different superheroes or different
characters in the universe and like the
days and weeks leading up to like the
end of the Multiverse the collapse of
everything and like this start of Secret
Wars for the character of Loki he was
accompanied by a chick named Verity
she's not really important here but the
character of Loki what had happened is
that following the events of of Siege on
Asgard when the Loki that we had always
known had basically been killed that
that version of Loki was reborn as what
was basically the god of stories instead
of the god of Lies he did have his own
set of events that were going on
honestly that was probably the coolest
version of Loki that we'd ever seen in
Marvel Comics he was literally going on
missions to make up for all of his
awesomest Deeds which was cool and so
what ended up happening is that during
the last day's event Loki ended up
leaving and going outside the Multiverse
and then once the last day's story arc
ended in agents of Asgard he basically
opened a door to see what came next now
the intention at that point in time is
it was basically him skipping everything
it was basically Loki saying okay he's
skipping past Secret Wars opening the
door and then going into the reborn
Multiverse what alguing did as part of
Defenders is he said actually before
Loki showed up after Secret Wars was
over he basically left he ended up you
know going back to the universe that
came before and that's how Loki's here
right that's why Loki's here at the
moment so it's really kind of a detour
right so like you're in California
you're driving down to Florida to Disney
World instead of going straight to
Disney World you stop and you go to
Texas for whatever reason makes sense to
nobody but yourself because who the hell
would want to go there but you stop in
Texas for a little bit that's what this
is right it's the equivalent of Loki
making a side stop in Texas and so with
this team basically assembled because
everybody's here did every read that
like literally the entire mission is
kind of etched in stone like there's no
way to undo this now right like they're
literally charted on this course and a
series of events outside of their
control are going to start happening
that will force them here and so as a
result of that one of the first things
that pops off is basically the portal to
the neutral zone ends up going awry now
the way the neutral zone has been
handled in Marvel Comics has shifted
over the years so one of the things to
know and I believe we covered this but
I'm not 100 sure that one of the things
we found out is that when it came to the
blue Marvel he actually had a son named
Kevin he actually had two sons one named
Max and one named Kevin but his son
Kevin had basically been sucked inside
the neutral zone and there was no real
conceivable means of getting him out and
so at that point in time the way the
neutral zone was established in Marvel
Comics is that it was a place outside
the Multiverse but led to what was
basically the Omniverse right so a
collection of multiverses and really it
was just an Uncharted place an Uncharted
realm we didn't really know anything
about it we just knew that it was a
place where matter and antimatter
coalesced the hypothesis among fans is
that because Kevin Brashear exists in
that realm if he's able to return to the
main Marvel Universe and simultaneously
use all the power that he's accumulated
or that has kind of infused with his
body while he was in the neutral zone
he'd be the most powerful force to ever
exist in the history of Marvel Comics
like everybody would fall before him his
power would dwarf everyone right
literally every character you've ever
seen or heard of in Marvel regardless of
the level of power they have up to and
presumably including the one above all
would be dwarfed by the power of Kevin
Brashear because at the end of the day
the one above all is the one who created
the entirety of the Multiverse what
happens when you're a being who's
powerful enough to basically leave the
purview of the one above all and achieve
a level of power that exceeds that of
the one above all but again that's all
just a fan Theory there's been nothing
to solidify that but what is going on
here is the neutral zone is basically a
place kind of an intro intermediary
right so you leave the Multiverse you go
into the neutral zone and then from the
neutral zone you can go into anywhere
beyond the Multiverse and so that's
really what they're looking at here the
kicker to all this is that with them
being sucked into the portal the first
thing to come across or the first being
they encounter is eternity and Eternity
literally tells them okay like you guys
are basically in liminal space at the
moment meaning you're within the
universe itself but you're transitioning
beyond the universe you know I can
essentially allow you to pass because
the threat that you're facing off
against exceeds anything that can
basically thwart it within the universe
right like you have to pass through me
to get there and I'm going to let you
because this threat's bad enough you
guys need to deal with it and so as a
result of that they pass through
eternity they exit the universe and they
end up basically in what lies beyond the
Multiverse initially all they encounter
is darkness and it's really Adam
Brashear kind of giving us this
explanation and saying that like
everything's gone right there is nothing
there they're passing through all these
different things now this mess with a
method of Passage where you're seeing
them going through what's basically
Darkness this is another instance where
things shift right so for example when
the far Shore was introduced in Marvel
Comics which is basically where Cosmic
entities go to die that the method of
transporting there that that was one of
those instances where you literally had
like transluminal space so you would see
like just these these bright lights and
all kinds of different stuff passing by
you and so on and so forth it was
literally just kind of a combination of
all kinds of crazy things right it's
just bright lights and shapes and just
sort of indiscernible stuff and so
having Darkness here is just another way
to show the same process but just
showing it in the form of Darkness it's
a little weird it's a little wonky but
it is a cool thing but what goes on is
that as Adam Brashear literally gives us
this explanation right he's like I don't
know exactly what's happening here I
can't even see anything so I don't even
know where we are right we're literally
flying through what is in effect space
and time and then eventually moving
beyond it and so he's like is it
happening now is it happening then it's
really more him just kind of talking to
himself to a degree and he even goes as
far as to say like we're moving faster
and faster and then we're going faster
yet again the void of nothing flips on
an invisible axis where crossing a
threshold coming in for a landing then
there's a voice in the darkness if I
were a younger man I'd think it was the
voice of God but I've been around for a
minute I know better than that I know
it's trouble and the voice simply says I
am from Beyond
that's why ladies and gentlemen this
that's right ladies and gentlemen yes
ladies and gentlemen the beyonder has
returned and here's the thing it's not
even just the beyonder who's returned
we'll find out in the next video that we
do it's the beyonders the race of
beyonders are back in Marvel Comics and
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with this the last time we saw the
beyonders they killed the Multiverse so
God only knows what's gonna happen next
but I will say this you think blue
Marvel's been powerful so far you
haven't seen anything yet because this
guy gets you a whole new level of power
that just defines the word broken
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with Defenders
Beyond and the ending of the story is
nuts oh my God it's so good the story
itself is amazing it's just ridiculously
awesome but what this does here is this
basically picks up with one of the
beyonders and I say that because we're
gonna see more but it picks up with one
of the beyonders and kind of the main
beyonder basically talking to the
Defenders and kind of giving us a sort
of new origin for everything now what Al
Ewing does here is he Blends the origin
of all things in existence from his
ultimates run with the beyonders
themselves so for those of you guys who
saw our videos on Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers oh my God that
story or you saw our videos on Al
Ewing's ultimates bear with me here
because we're going to kind of bring
this together for people who haven't so
the idea behind this is what the
beyonder says in the beginning there was
the first firmament now the way this
origin worked in Al Ewing's ultimates
and he really again is kind of carrying
it over here the first firmament was
basically created by the one above all
that's the only real indication that we
ever get when it comes to its existence
but the idea is the first firmament was
basically the only thing in existence
you can call it a universe if you want
to and what the first firmament did is
it created a group of beings that were
called the aspirins and these aspirins
were monochrome in nature right they
were black and white and that was it the
idea behind this is that the aspirants
traveled around the universe they
created galaxies Stars solar systems
planets life all that kind of stuff but
whenever they created anything they went
to the first firmament and they sought
its approval if the first firmament
hated what the aspirants had done then
the aspirants would destroy their
creation and they would start over if
the first firmament approved of the
creation then that creation would
continue on but there was a subsect of
the aspirants who actually disagreed
with the idea of seeking approval for
their creations and believe that things
should change and evolve and grow and so
what this subsect did is it gave
themselves colors in a different form
and started calling themselves the
celestials and then ultimately a holy
war broke out a war between those who
were faithful to the to the first
firmament and those who were not these
celestials ultimately won but in doing
so shattered the first firmament into an
infinite number of pieces and that's
where the first Multiverse comes from
and so when that happened the birth of
the first Multiverse led to an infinite
number of possibilities and that's why
as the beyonder explains this he says
that what we got was a Multiverse of
possibility where each what if would
become its own what is because prior to
the Multiverse it was just what if this
happened what if that happened and you
would never find out but when the
Multiverse came into existence it was
what if this happened and then that what
if became its own universe meaning it
became what is and so as time progressed
this is where the origin of the
beyonders comes into play and it's a
part that might prove to be a little
controversial because of the fact that a
holy war did break out between the
aspirants and the celestials in order to
prevent a holy war like that happening
again seemingly the end of all things
the celestials created the Beyond and
the idea was that the honors were
created with such a level of power they
could destroy the celestials if they
needed to hence the reason why they were
a Fail-Safe it wouldn't make any sense
for the celestials to create a group of
beings that could prevent any kind of a
Celestial war from happening if those
beings were incapable of destroying
celestials and so ultimately what ended
up happening is when the beyonders were
created by the celestials they literally
just existed out there right in the
Beyond verse as just kind of a thing
where it was like a Fail-Safe right if
things pop off between the celestials a
great big huge War takes place and all
things could be jeopardized the
beyonders could step in they could
annihilate those celestials recreate
them and then leave again right that's
literally all it would be the kicker
about all this and what's so interesting
is you literally have the question
that's asked by Blue Marvel in them
right like they're kind of like okay so
how do you reconcile basically the
destruction of the seventh Cosmos I.E
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers and Secret Wars in 2015. but
before we get to that answer one of the
things that's really kind of asked here
is this beyonder they're talking to is
it the same beyonder from the original
Secret Wars in 1984 and the response to
this beyonder is yes I am definitively
that beyonder but I'm the more adult
version now here's where things get
interesting right and here's where we
kind of bring in Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers and reconcile those things
so when Jonathan Hickman wrote Avengers
and New Avengers and he introduced the
ivory Kings the beyonders whatever you
want to call him right the white Lords
of wild space which I still say is one
of the coolest names for the beyonders
in the history of Marvel Comics when
that whole thing happened what we didn't
know was how you reconcile the beyonders
with the beyonder that we saw before and
while Hickman did that in a pretty
significant way or pretty basic way like
literally it was Black Panther analyzing
it and saying that version of the
beyonder was a child unit or at least I
think it was Hing Pym who said it maybe
the important thing is he didn't really
go that far in reconciling them what Al
Ewing does here is he says okay so when
it comes to this original beyonder that
when the molecule man Owen Reese first
gained his powers he did so by basically
puncturing a hole into the Beyond verse
without realizing it he was basically
creating a Cosmic Cube and didn't know
it and so we're half that power went
into the molecule man the other half of
that power was basically the beyonder
which was still in an infant state but
because that hole was punched that hole
remained which meant that this baby
beyonder if you want to call it that
looked through that hole and saw the
entirety of the Marvel Multiverse on the
other side and was exceedingly curious
about it and that's why the beyonder did
what it did during Secret Wars in 1984
and that's why that beyonder seems brand
new it doesn't understand superheroes
it's easily manipulated by Dr Doom
different things along those lines right
it's more curious about superheroes than
anything else why do good guys fight bad
guys why do good guys fight good guys
right why do things like that happen the
reason why this beyonder looks the way
it does right now with like the great
big huge silver shoulder straps and all
that kind of stuff is because that's the
the last form that it took before we
basically saw its non-existence right
before it seemingly ceased to exist when
we saw it in secret Wars 2 and then the
unofficial Fantastic Four Secret Wars
follow-up which basically saw the
beyonder and molecule man merging into a
Cosmic Cube together by and large Al
Ewing is ignoring that Fantastic Four
story so we can also ignore it as well
so basically this form that we see with
the beyonder is the last time we saw it
in terms of his physical appearance and
so it's kind of cool here because one of
the things that the beyonders say here
is that in this place where the
Defenders are at they're beyond the
Multiverse and the reality is they
cannot observe the beyonders in their
most pure form so that's why the
beyonders took on a physical form made
of matter in order to communicate with
them it's not that dissimilar from what
the cosmic entities do what the cosmic
entities do is they go to a realm called
the dimension of manifestations and they
meet with a being called anthropomorpho
and anthropomorpho gives them a physical
form that their quote-unquote concept
can house and then they appear in the
main Marvel Universe it's just one of
those things that takes place that was
established back in the old Quasar
comics in the early 1990s but the thing
about this is that's why the beyonders
appear the way they do is because it's
really the only way that these guys
could understand them and so following
back to our question where they ask
about Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers the collapse of the
Multiverse the grand experiment is that
in that story what Jonathan Hickman had
established is that the origin of
molecule man Owen Reese is exact across
every Universe it's the exact same
origin and the reason for that is
because what the beyonders wanted to do
is they wanted to basically ensure that
someone like the molecule man could
basically house an astronomical amount
of power because remember Owen Reese was
powerful enough where he was powerful on
a multiversal level he was
astronomically powerful but when he dies
right when he is destroyed he wipes out
a whole universe in the process the idea
of the beyonders was to detonate the
molecule man Owen Reese across every
single universe and blow up every
universe and destroy the Multiverse in
the process at the time that Jonathan
Hickman wrote that story it was just an
experiment and that was it what Al Ewing
establishes here is that there was
actually a motivation behind it that the
reality and it's not really overly
explained here it's just kind of a more
of a hand wavy thing than anything else
but what the be honors were doing is
what was basically called a controlled
demolition like when a city destroys a
building it was literally one of those
things where they were like it was time
for the seventh Cosmos to end right we
had to end it so that we could basically
stop some major coming threat called the
Dominion and we don't exactly know what
it is but it's just some major threat
that exists out there that's going to
arrive and when it does basically
everything's going to be destroyed the
hopes of the beyonders was to basically
keep that threat from coming at Bay by
destroying the seventh Cosmos but as we
know while the seventh Cosmos was
destroyed right the Multiverse did die
Doctor Doom sees the Power of the
beyonders for himself he brought
everything back or most everything back
in the form of battle world and then at
the end of Secret Wars the power of the
beyonders was taken from Dr Doom by the
molecule man given to Reed Richards of
the Fantastic Four and read Richard said
everything back that by and large what
it basically meant is everything was
effectively reset to the way it was
before the events of Avengers and New
Avengers ever happened meaning the
threat of the Dominion remains it was
never stopped and so as a result of that
while this is a kind of New Concept we
didn't know about the Dominion before
that ultimately the superheroes
literally secured their own demise and
so at the moment the beyonders are
actually trying to figure out a way to
stop the Dominion from appearing because
they know if they were to try to
initiate some major multiversal
cataclysm like they did before then
ultimately there'd be no way of stopping
it the superheroes would ultimately
prevent it from happening right Secret
Wars would happen all over again and so
one of the crazy things that goes on is
that you do have this bit of a
discussion and for the be honors
themselves they appear very human in
nature right in terms of how they
communicate how they talk how they act
because it's a way that human beings
would be able to identify with that the
thing about this is the beyonders intend
to destroy the Defenders because if the
Defenders travel further it could
complicate whatever plans the beyonders
have now the reason why the beyonders
want to even destroy the defenders in
the first place beyond complicating
their plans is they know the Defenders
will try to push further beyond the
Beyond verse which is really kind of an
interesting theme because in Marvel
Comics there was no indication that
there was anything beyond the Beyond
verse outside of like the far Shore
right where like Cosmic entities go to
die that was it right the far Shore is
as close as you get to the realm of the
one above all and even depending on
who's telling the story it in fact is
the realm of the one above all right it
really just kind of depends on what's
going on but the thing about this is
that the Defenders will try to push
further they'll try to go beyond and as
a result of that the beyonder is trying
to destroy them right now we'll
basically keep that from happening and
so blue Marvel gives America Chavez The
Eternity mask because remember the
eternity mask is basically a plot device
right it's just a giant McGuffin it'll
allow who's ever whoever's wearing it to
have power on par with whoever they're
fighting what this establishes is that
there's no limit to the level of power
that the eternity mask can copy because
you literally have America Chavez who
gets into a hand-to-hand fight with the
beyonder itself but while she's dealing
with the main beyonder you in turn have
the other beyonders that try to destroy
the Defenders now the cool thing about
this and kind of a caveat here is
remember Loki is now the god of stories
which means that Loki controls the
narrative it's basically a meditable way
of Al Ewing saying like Loki controls
what happens in a story so it's really
kind of a weird thing because at this
point Loki's like you're now confined to
the stories that I create and if the
story that I create says we as the
Defenders will find a way to destroy you
then that means we as the Defenders will
find a way to destroy you right like
that's going to happen there's no
conceivable way to stop it it's simply
just a matter of time now there it's
kind of one of those open-ended things
where maybe the Defenders like die here
they come back at some future point in
time and they destroy the beyonders then
we don't really know like it's just one
of those things where their defeat is
governed so literally everything that
you see transpiring from this point
going forward is being done so based on
the story narrative that Loki has
created I know it's kind of weird it's a
little wonky Al Ewing can be a little
zany with how he writes his stories the
content in the stories is amazing but
the way he tells them is a little weird
right if you don't believe me look no
further than the immortal Hulk
because literally at the end of that
story we find out what happens when the
one above all hulks out and basically he
becomes the one below all and is kind of
nuts but as this beyonder is trying to
destroy the different members of The
Defenders blue Marvel basically charges
up and destroys this beyonder himself
right literally blue Marvel kills a
beyonder now he does but he doesn't
right like he basically destroys the
physical form of the beyonder but the
reality here is that these guys are
living raw power right just Raw Creation
in its most pure form they cannot be
truly annihilated and destroyed they can
only ever be destroyed in the moment
right temporarily that's all they can
ever really do but because it is a body
made of matter and and blue Marvel is a
living antimatter reactor it's literally
just a knife punching holes and cheese
that's all it is right just it's a hot
knife through butter so he just destroys
this physical form of the beyonder and
that's basically it now eventually it
does reconstitute itself but they also
realize that there's basically a portal
that the honors have that will allow the
Defenders to transport Beyond right to
move Beyond and so literally The
Defenders end up traveling through this
portal and then the the kind of main
beyonder from Secret Wars follows them
and what they end up doing and it's
really one of these one of these crazy
things the beyonders ask the question
the broken one gives Chase right the
broken beyonder is what they what they
call them and they ask should we prevent
this and the statements made don't
succumb to narrative forces we have done
all we can if the Defenders choose to
Traverse beyond the Beyond they have
chosen the path of trial they have
chosen fire and so what we're literally
told here is fire and Limitless light
yawning wide for eternity's Defenders as
Taya opens herself up for the white hot
heart that turns a cosmos and speaks
life at the edge of life's end and so
she's met by this kind of disembodied
voice and it seemingly takes her over
right literally it says you called out
in defiance of death I heard and I came
now anybody who's familiar with Marvel
Comics anybody who knows who knows
anything about Marvel Comics in relation
to Chris claremont's run of the X-Men
you know exactly who this is because
you've seen this statement before you've
read this statement before where a
person was dying and their mind called
out in defiance of death for some some
form of Aid and a figure appeared that
saved them and everybody else they knew
from death and so suddenly you have this
figure who appears to The Defenders and
says Defenders hear me no longer am I
the science ear that you knew I am tired
no more I am Fire and Life incarnate now
and forever I am the Phoenix quite
literally The Defenders have traveled to
the white hot room now for those of you
guys who don't know who what the white
hot room is you'll find out next week
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Defenders Beyond and blue
Marvel fights the Phoenix Force plus
we're also going to find out uh how the
beyonder ranks in comparison to the
Phoenix
I'm curious to see how you guys respond
so as we covered in the last video
basically blue Marvel The Defenders and
them had come across the beyonders and
we got it what was in effect the new
origin of the beyonders in Marvel Comics
they were effectively created by the
celestials and given enough power to
ensure they could destroy the celestials
if they needed to and so what we ended
up finding at the end of that story is
that the Defenders passed through the
beyonders and into the next stage of
existence right the higher planes as it
was called and into the white hot room
now this requires a bit of a discussion
here and this is one of the things I
wanted to hold off until this video so
in Marvel Comics a lot of you guys are
aware of the Phoenix Force even if you
don't necessarily know the ins and outs
of the Phoenix Force the idea behind the
Phoenix is that there is only one
Phoenix Force throughout the entirety of
the Multiverse and even Omniverse but in
Marvel Comics in recent years they've
used Multiverse and Omniverse
interchangeably so they more or less
mean the same thing in Marvel Comics now
but the idea behind it is there's only
ever one Phoenix Force just like there's
only one Living Tribunal the idea behind
the Phoenix though is that it represents
the sum total of all life that has ever
currently does and will ever exist
throughout the Multiverse now we know
just by nature of the history of Marvel
Comics not even including Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers that
the Multiverse does have an end date it
will end naturally at some point in time
so that's how Marvel creates a sort of
cap to the power of the Phoenix but when
you're talking about a level of power
that high the cap on the Phoenix Force's
Powers is so astronomically up there you
might as well consider that it doesn't
even exist because there'd be very very
few instances where you would see the
Phoenix Force go up against a level of
power that it just cannot handle the
only real exception to this is when the
Phoenix takes on a physical host The
Perfect Host was Jean Gray right that's
why Jean Gray and the Phoenix are so
synonymous it has taken on the bodies of
beings like Quentin choir or at least in
an alternate reality it did in alternate
reality Franklin Richards became the
Phoenix Rachel Summers is a popular host
for the Phoenix but the Phoenix's
ability to utilize those avatars is
relative to what the Avatar's bodies can
handle so it's like pouring water in a
glass if you pour too much it's going to
overflow the Overflow equivalent in
Marvel Comics is that physical being
dying right that's basically what that
is and so the white hot room is
basically this place within the
Multiverse whereby the Phoenix Force
resides it's its home and it's in the
white hot room that the Phoenix force is
at the absolute peak of its power and so
one of the things to know is that as
they pass into this place they are in
the white hot room it's where the
Phoenix is its most capable you'll never
find the Phoenix Force ever being more
powerful than it is when it's in the
white hot room now the first person that
we initially pick up with is Tigra
antigra doesn't fully understand what's
going on here instead they've all seemed
to have kind of arrived in different
locations really within the white hot
room if there is such a thing and the
result is that Tigra initially
communicates with the Phoenix right
literally the Phoenix pops up and it
says I am Fire and Life incarnate and my
wings beat Thunder I am the glory at the
heart of all things the Roaring flame of
mercy and terrible judgment beyond me me
there is Darkness human Darkness Without
End do you understand now here's the
thing to understand there is a realm
beyond the realm of the Phoenix and
that's something that I hope you guys
are really picking up on here with what
Al Ewing's doing he's kind of building
it in layers right he's like there's the
main Marvel universe beyond the main
Marvel Universe there is the Multiverse
beyond the Multiverse there's the Beyond
verse beyond the Beyond verse there is
the white hot room beyond the white hot
room is a place that we will see at the
end of this comic and actually in the
next comic as well what's ironic about
that is that if you have an Eagle Eye in
Marvel Comics really in the events
leading up to Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers are really
Secret Wars you know what room we're
talking about it's a really really cool
place it's a place that the Silver
Surfer visited once so there's a really
awesome location but the thing about
this is we switch over to Adam Brashear
now Adam Brashear in communicating with
the Phoenix force is one of these cool
things because Adam kind of asked where
you have like this construction worker
who's building things and working on
stuff Adam asked the question is that
being an Avatar of you now the reality
of this is that Al Ewing is sort of
building on an old story that was done
back in the day where basically Jean
Gray had met mistress death in the form
of a guy now I want to say it was during
dark Phoenix that's one of those areas
of Marvel Comics where as much as I love
the X-Men the memories do get a little
murky and so I can't necessarily recall
the location of the comic isn't overly
important here what is important is that
when Jean Gray Met Death that death was
actually building these pillars in her
own realm and these pillars were
basically the afterlife for every
individual being who died now that was
Chris claremont's depiction of the realm
of death it has different depictions
based on who you're talking to if you
read a comment by Jim Starlin that
features Thanos in the realm of mistress
death it'll be shown one way right so
it's just it really depends on who's
drawing and writing and interpreting the
story and so on and so forth but the
important thing here is that what the
Phoenix says is the reason why this
construction workers building is because
the job of the Phoenix is to always
build now that's true and that's been a
thing since Grant more since here comes
tomorrow during his new X-Men run the
idea behind the Phoenix by and large
right while it does exist and it does
have an incredible amount of power when
Grant Morrison initially introduced the
quote-unquote core rule of the Phoenix
that it was very very nebulous right it
was just like I exist to fix what's
broken but what the hell does that mean
Grant Morrison like I mean nobody knows
what that like what does it mean to fix
what's broken like what if something's
kind of broken a little bit but not
really right if a glass is cracked you
take it to a person who's going to be
able to like fix it or do you just say
you know what we'll wait till it starts
leaking water like how does that how
does that work right I mean how do you
square that Circle and so the role
behind the Phoenix is that it's always
building basically new universes new
places where people can reside where
life can grow so it's kind of the
Wellspring of all existence and so Adam
Brashear ever the scientist really has
more questions than anything else and
the answers that he gets are just very
very nebulous and very ambiguous right
he's literally like he asked a question
so what does that make him right the
construction worker your creation and
aspect of your being and there response
to the construction worker is I am as I
am Adam Brashear and I'm working there's
always the new to build on the old
always the schedule to keep and so his
question is so your God or your death am
I getting warm at least like give me
some kind of an answer and he doesn't
really get one but from here we switch
over to America Chavez now America
Chavez of course is also visited by the
Phoenix and as she's making her way
through this kind of endless desert the
Phoenix literally tells her you've lost
what it was that made you unique you can
get it back but it's going to be a very
very arduous task now what the Phoenix
is referring to here is that when
America Chavez was initially introduced
into Marvel Comics she was a character
that had the ability to jump through
realities that was her thing much like
what you saw in Doctor Strange 2
Multiverse of Madness a giant star would
appear she jumped through it that star
was a portal she'd end up somewhere else
initially it happened without her
ability to control to a degree as time
progressed she gained more control over
it and that allowed her to jump in and
out of whatever reality she wanted to so
long as she was aware of where it was
and so as a result of that it's really
Al Ewing saying the ability for her to
regain her powers does exist and that
will eventually happen it'll just take a
little bit before it does at that point
we switch over to Loki and the beyonder
now this is where things get really
really interesting here and I'm really
curious to see how you guys feel about
this right the beyonder versus the
Phoenix I'm curious to see what you guys
think so one of the first things the
beyonder does is he basically makes a
food processor because the beyonder can
just do virtually anything it wants to
and just craft something out of nothing
right it's just the nature of the
beyonder's power he's as close as you
get to God but the funny thing about
this is that when Loki asked the
question the beyonder says I made it
when we landed forging the base quirks
that was the hard part right basically
making it was the hard part do you want
to blend anything I find it's comforting
in moments like this and when Loki asks
moments like what the response of the
beyonder moments when I'm outclassed
silly if you hadn't trapped me in a
narrative Arc I would never have come
here I mean I'm omnipotent of course
technically speaking but against the
pure Phoenix Force actually inside the
White hot room we're probably going to
end up like Mr Carrot here so what Al
Ewing is establishing is the Phoenix
force in its most pure form it's more
powerful than the beyonder now there's
room to make this argument here there's
room to make this argument because
remember every single time anyone's ever
gone up against the Beyond Rachel
Summers when she was the Phoenix
fighting the beyonder in secret Wars 2
when Cyclops was killed by God King Doom
wielding the power of the beyonders when
he had the Phoenix force or at least
when Cyclops had the Phoenix Force every
time we've seen the Phoenix face off
against the beyonder it's always been
the Phoenix with a physical host and the
Phoenix's power is always diminished
when it has a physical host because
outside of Jean Gray no one's been able
to wield the full totality of the
Phoenix and become the white Phoenix of
the crown in its most pure form so Al
Ewing is actually going with credible
evidence here right given the fact that
the Phoenix course is absolute power
life incarnate it stands to reason you
could make an argument the Phoenix could
defeat the beyonder now some people will
kind of like say no that's ridiculous
largely because it's just like the
Beyond are supposed to be like the most
powerful being out there next to God and
if we're talking about the original
beyonder from Secret Wars one and two
yes but lest we forget and the Fantastic
Four stories that were done back in the
day that retcon happened the beyonder's
power was reduced by about half so that
kind of begs the question in terms of a
tried and true beyonder which is what
this guy now is would the Phoenix be
able to defeat it I'm not 100 sure
there's no definitive answer here
because I don't think there's really any
credible evidence to offer either way
outside of some stuff that Phoenix has
done some stuff that beyonder's done
comparing the two of them and coming to
a conclusion so here's what I want the
comic book YouTube Community not just
the fans anybody in the comic book
YouTube Community who finds who who
wants to get into this give me an answer
because I'm curious right I mean I'm
sure look at a power scale do a little
bit of cooking of the books but you know
let me know right what do you think
would actually happen here like do you
think the pure Phoenix Force could
actually defeat the beyonder that it is
more powerful than the beyonder I'm
curious right somebody gave me some some
answers here because honestly I'm
excited to see if anybody can figure it
out but the thing about this is that
once this sort of statement is known
right once this thing is known we
basically jump back to of course the
Phoenix sort of taunting Loki and the
beyonder a little bit the Loki's kind of
ignoring her more than anything else and
one of the things that Phoenix says is
that that version of Loki has to be
destroyed because it's a Loki out of
time remember that's one of the things
that we covered that leading up to
Jonathan Hickman's Secret Wars Marvel
had stories that were called uh the last
days of whoever in the heck was in that
story in this instance the last days of
Loki that Loki basically skipped over
the entirety of Secret Wars went through
a portal went back in time and that's
how he's here but Loki is not actually
supposed to be here right now he's
supposed to be dead he was supposed to
have been wiped away with everything
right with the Multiverse and then be
reborn I as its current self so it's one
of those weird things it's a little
weird and a little murky and kind of
wonky but just understand this version
of Loki is not supposed to exist and so
that's what the Phoenix is talking about
here when it says you're supposed to be
burned away You're supposed to be gone
but switching over to this fight between
blue Marvel Adam Brashear and uh and the
Phoenix Force the fight between the two
is really really intriguing here and the
reason why is because Al Ewing is
building on this in the sense that one
Al Ewing is probably the second most
prolific writer of Adam Brashear outside
of Kevin grievius who made him right for
those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with that Kevin grievius made
Adam Brashear and then Al Ewing wrote
the heroic age story I believe where uh
where Adam Brashear fought Hyperion from
a different universe but after that all
of the appearances of Adam brashear's
character in Marvel Comics have all been
written by Al hewing the mighty Avengers
led by Luke Cage was Al healing the
ultimate Al Ewing this is all Al Ewing
that's been writing his character so
he's pretty well versed and what he's
capable of the Phoenix Force for all of
its power and all this bravado and all
of its abilities is a being made of
positive matter so there is room albeit
arguing kind of fudging the numbers a
little bit there is room for Adam
Brashear to either be comparable to the
Phoenix Force even if only temporarily
or at least to negate its power because
that's antimatter versus positive matter
so again it's uh it's interesting here
it's one of those ways where it's
basically blue Marvel kind of getting a
power boost or Adam brochure getting a
power boost one that we hadn't normally
seen before because this will be
referenced across the internet people
will say well there was that time when
Adam Brashear went toe-to-toe against
the Phoenix and then somebody's going to
come back and say yeah but this and that
person is going to come back and say
yeah but that and this is how it works
on the internet but it's just one of
those interesting things because in the
midst of the fight between the two you
do have the beyonder and Loki who show
up and the beyonder throws a food
processor at the Phoenix and hits her in
the head which is kind of weird but it's
one of those things where what it does
is it offers a momentary reprieve
because it allows America Chavez who's
basically returned to jump in and fight
the Phoenix now remember America Chavez
has the eternity mask which grants her
power that's equal to whoever she's
facing off against that's not even an
alewing invention as far as I'm aware
this thing's been around for years and
years and years of Marvel Comics what it
does is it allows everybody else the
time they need to basically start trying
to figure out a way out of there and
that's where you have Adam Brashear who
starts talking directly to uh to the
construction worker and it's kind of a
cool thing because while the
construction worker is doing all of this
Al Ewing does kind of hint to the idea
that the construction worker is not
associated with the Phoenix that it's
not necessarily directly with the
Phoenix itself and in fact one of the
things that construction worker says is
he says this place is a place of balance
between light and dark compassion and
severity mercy and destruction your
friends are acting out that balance
there's an argument for letting you all
Journey on just as there's an argument
for burning you to nothing and so Adam
asks like that's not a debate that I
want to risk playing out do you have any
advice mysterious stranger and this guy
says me I just work here you're the one
leading eternity's Defenders you're the
one calling the plays and so it's an
interesting thing because what this guy
looks like is again he's not associated
with the Phoenix Force which is to say
he's not a part of the Phoenix now there
is a person in Marvel Comics recently
that has been talking about balance and
if any of you guys have read the the
newer Thanos one shot that came out that
recently retold his origin which we'll
cover tomorrow that mistress death says
that that mistress death is like no
Thanos is acting out of balance right
he's playing a balance that kind of
thing so whether or not this is actually
mistress death is just one of those
things that's a mystery but again it is
cool to see that there's this kind of
figure out there that doesn't really
have a direct relation to the Phoenix
per se so again it's sort of fascinating
here because in the midst of all this
you have Adam Brashear that comes to
this realization that with somebody like
Tigra she's a lot more powerful than she
initially appears now here's the thing
about here's the thing about Greer
Nelson one I know most of you guys don't
care about Greer and that's fair she
sucks she always has and she's never
been interesting but the thing about her
character is that she gained her powers
and she plays a role similar to t'challa
of the Black Panther Mythos where
t'challa is an avatar of the panther
goddess best Tigra is an avatar of what
is basically the Tiger Force or the
Tiger God if you want to call it that it
all goes back to her origin her
professor named tumulo who basically
turned out to be a guy that was involved
with a whole bunch of magicians that
worshiped like a tiger goddess it's
weird and it's wonky and it's Marvel
Comics back in the day and it's one of
the stories didn't really make a whole
lot of sense the important thing here is
she's got a level of power that she
didn't know she had and she's never
tapped into before and so in doing so
what it does is that by utilizing this
power of the tiger God she kind of
communes with it channels its abilities
and then goes on to the affront
basically attacking the Phoenix now
again this is Al Ewing kind of offering
this idea the Phoenix force is powerful
but it's not the most powerful being out
there beyond that what it's also saying
is that yeah it's it's more powerful
than the beyonder but there are gods is
out there that are more powerful than
the Phoenix what you're witnessing here
over the course of the story is Al Ewing
giving us a wholesale reshuffling of the
Marvel Cosmic Landscape of the power
hierarchy because in years past the
Marvel Comics right in years past what
you had is you had the one above all
then you had to be under then you had
the molecule man then you had everybody
else right the Living Tribunal and
Eternity and their powers fluctuated
based on the situation and who was
writing the stories so on and so forth
right then you had the introduction of
characters like the Marquee of death
Clyde wincham which elevated him to a
higher position you had characters with
caveats so like Thanos with the astral
regulator or Thanos with the heart of
the universe or Thanos with The Infinity
Gauntlet or whatever plot device Marvel
wants to create so he can go on some
crazy omnipotent scheme but whatever the
case is like you always had this kind of
established hierarchy among the cosmic
entities the gods so on and so forth
there's never been an instance where
we've ever looked at a character like
bass or any Earthly based God and
consider the possibility that they would
be on par with something as
astronomically powerful as the Phoenix
the Phoenix permeates the Multiverse
bass is just a being over there who sits
in that chair and appears sometimes in
Marvel Comics and like that's it right
so like this God you know this this
goddess this tiger god kind of falls in
the same vein so it is interesting to
see how Ewing just reshuffling so much
of this what the purpose is I'm not
entirely sure that's why stories like
this can kind of go either way either
this story is one where What's Happening
Here is going to permeate throughout the
entirety of the MCU so they're making
things a little more reasonable so the
Marvel Cinematic Universe can match it
the alternative is Al Ewing's doing this
because he wants to and he can right
because it's Al Ewing and I'll read
anything this guy does and it's awesome
right so I mean again it's just one of
those funny and and sort of wonky
situations but in the midst of this
whole thing while this fight's going on
between basically the the Phoenix and
the tiger god again it gives the
Defenders the chance to move beyond the
realm of the white hot room and into
what's called The Abyss the Place Beyond
now once they're here they initially
have no idea what's here everything's
black and white there's no real color
here or anything everything's just sort
of drained out almost as if it's things
that haven't necessarily come to
fruition yet but the funny thing is when
they start asking questions and saying
like what in the world's going on here
like everything just feels so wrong in
this place a disembodied voice comes out
of nowhere and says of course it does
you all died by fire and now you're in
the abyss with me but don't worry even
here glorion can make your dreams come
true now here's the thing about glorion
right for those of you guys who don't
know anything about this guy this guy is
eight kinds of broken this guy's just
like eight not even just physically the
level of power this guy has is nuts he's
the most powerful being in Marvel Comics
that you've never heard of because this
guy draws his power from the shaper of
world and the shaper of Worlds is
literally a walking talking Cosmic Cube
that's basically what this guy is this
guy can do anything now in years past he
hasn't been a being that was on par with
the Phoenix or more powerful than the
Phoenix or even the beyonders but what
it looks like Al Ewing is doing here is
saying that in this place right the land
of couldn't be shouldn't be which is
exactly what the abyss is that glorion
is the most powerful man walking and I'm
curious to see what in the world comes
out of this
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with Defenders
Beyond and we are here with two of the
most powerful beings that you've never
heard of one of whom is a cosmic entity
so what this does here picking up off
the heels of the last video is it
initially picks up with Adam rashier the
blue Marvel right and so this guy
actually saves President Kennedy from
being taken out by Lee Harvey Oswald now
of course he appears to President
Kennedy and is just kind of like imagine
what would have happened if I'd have
learned about this on TV and he even
goes as far as to tell him like you
better have your concession speech ready
Mr Kennedy because the next time you
hear from me it's going to be in the
primaries and then following that it
picks up really in kind of the present
day after blue Marvel has won the
presidency and of course retired the
presidency was decades ago and then in
turn it's just kind of celebrating with
all the different members of The
Avengers and you'll notice the Avengers
look different than they normally do
Spider-Man is still wearing the suit
that he got in secret Wars the beyonder
is currently around which he's not
technically part of the event you're
seeing a team and a group of people that
don't necessarily exist in their current
form Tigra for whatever reason that
makes sense to nobody but Al Ewing is
basically the leader of the Avengers and
has the power to lift Thor's hammer it's
one of these funny things because what
you're seeing here is an alteration of
reality as most of you guys know from
reading the history of Adam Brashear in
Marvel Comics he was asked to step down
by President Kennedy and where this
story really seems to maintain that
conversation between the two unlike what
we saw in the main Marvel Universe with
Adam Brashear in this reality he chose
not to step down and in fact he ignored
President Kennedy's order and continued
operating as a superhero and was then
successfully elected to the presidency
of the United States and from there you
pick up with America Chavez who has her
sister in tow and has also met with her
mothers in the utopian parallel the real
utopian parallel right so her mothers
are alive beyond that you have the
arrival of Taya the mother of Galactus
and when she gets there of course
Galactus is in toe which gives a us the
return of lifebringer Galactus now we're
going to make sense of all this here in
a second because it's important that you
understand what's going on here beyond
the different alterations of reality
involving like the Avengers and so on
and so forth this ties into the work
that Al Ewing's done already so for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with Taya and are unfamiliar with the
lifebringer Taya was introduced in the
main defender's story that was written
by Al Ewing technically Defenders Beyond
is kind of a spin-off slash sort of
ending of the defender's story as Al
Ewing had done it but Taya was brought
in when you basically had the Defenders
who had transitioned to the previous
reality before the current one and they
discovered the parents of Galactus now
is kind of alewing reworking everything
sort of adjusting everything to sort of
fit his needs but the thing about this
is that lifebringer Galactus originated
in Al Ewing's ultimates run that in all
new all different Marvel when the
ultimates were launched which was
honestly if I'm being quite Frank with
you guys the ultimates comic book was
the best comic that no one was reading
right that thing was the best thing
going in all new Alder from Marvel and I
don't care what anybody says it was a
ridiculously phenomenal story check this
out the team was nuts you had the blue
Marvel who led the team you had black
panther America Chavez Captain Marvel
Monica Rambo and then eventually you had
Auntie man Connor since it was nuts like
it was so powerful the first thing they
did was fight and overpower Galactus and
then continue his Evolution right the
the situation that alewing presented was
that when Galactus emerged and started
consuming worlds that he hadn't fully
evolved what the ultimates did is they
evolved him to his final form which was
the lifebringer so he literally started
traveling around the universe bringing
back all the worlds that he had
previously consumed it was pretty
awesome the crazy thing about this is
that we get this kind of monologue
coming from America Chavez where she
says that for a moment all of this just
feels Perfect all of us together in
celebration in an ideal world there's
not even any villains which really begs
the question why did The Avengers even
exist in the first place right that this
whole thing is perfect and that it's too
perfect she realizes there's something
on her face that she's wearing the
eternity mask and that's when she breaks
free of this false reality and we
realize that none of what she's seeing
is actually real now of course glorion
is the one behind all of this and he
even goes so far is to alter reality and
to say okay fine if what you want is the
real Galactus then here's the real
Galactus and he shows her just like this
monstrosity Galactus like as we know him
right the Devourer of Worlds and it's
kind of nuts because you have him really
talking to America Chavez and coming to
this realization The Eternity mask even
outside all universes some things are
Universal and it makes you the equal of
anyone you fight so it gives you the
power to break free of my illusory
worlds but why would you want to fight
me look what it's doing to all of the
others and so he goes as far as to tell
America Chavez look at Taya finally
confronting the knowledge of what her
little gallon would become when that
universe that they're in dies and he's
born into the new universe I could give
her false hope again if you ask and when
America Chavez asks what is this place
his response is I told you you're in the
abyss the land of couldn't be shouldn't
be the furthest place from reality there
is nothing happens here there are no
stories and it's one of those things
because what Marvel really gives us and
what Al Ewing's been doing kind of
consolidating really everything he's
done in Marvel Comics so far especially
considering what we have here is that as
we mentioned in the last video you have
a universe right the main Marvel
Universe if we want to call it that
beyond the main Marvel Universe you have
the Multiverse beyond the Multiverse you
have the Beyond realm where the
beyonders reside beyond that you have
the white hot room where the white
Phoenix of the crown resides and then
beyond that you have this the land of
couldn't be shouldn't be now the funny
thing about this is that Al Ewing didn't
invent any of these outside of like the
far Shore which is basically where
Cosmic entities go to die and by all
standards the measurement is the realm
of the one above all and I don't
necessarily know how you reconcile that
place with this place the important
thing here is that in these locations
right in these Realms it was all
invented before him the land of couldn't
be shouldn't be as far as I'm aware that
was invented by Dan slot in a Silver
Surfer run now the thing about the land
of couldn't be shouldn't be is that this
is the place where basically only ideas
reside things that have never really
come to fruition right so if the
possibility exists out there this is
where that possibility resides before it
becomes real it's a very meta textual
realm but again glorion is the one that
rules in this realm seemingly at this
place now the reason why I say this
guy's so astronomically powerful is
because what this guy does is remove a
piece of himself and create a whole
entire Multiverse out of it like a
Multiverse of possibilities because as
he's talking to America Chavez he says
you're the one that's breaking things
around here America Chavez what I want
is to make these things true before I
died before I was trapped here I had the
chance to be become the living
personification of the Multiverse and my
eighth Cosmos would not have been a mere
continuation it would have been a cosmic
reboot a new beginning for everyone what
he's referring to is basically the
universe as it exists now after the
events of Secret Wars 2015. remember
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers The New
Avengers run basically detailed the idea
of the beyonders intending to wipe out
the entirety of the Multiverse had they
been successful the Multiverse would
have restarted because it's the natural
order of things but what glorian is
saying here is that in his mind what he
would have done after becoming the
embodiment of all things in existence
the entirety of the Multiverse he would
have rebooted in some ways I have to
believe this is Al Ewing basically
saying if I were the one running the
show I would have rebooted the entire
landscape of Marvel Comics he says look
America Chavez look at what the Dead
Land could be and that's when it kind of
astonishes her because she's like you're
using your own substance to make an
entire Multiverse and he says for now
but if you you choose this paradise that
I've made for you give it something of
yours we can keep it going together I.E
if you believe in this and if you choose
to become a part of this reality you
will now exist in an alternate reality
you'll exist in an alternate universe
because you believing in it has given it
form it's one of those really really
cool but metatual things and in fact
lorian says like look at what I've done
for all of you right Adam Brashear has
the answer to the one question that
torments him what might have been Taya
gets to be proud of her son Tigres an
a-lister with the respect of her peers
which is kind of funny because the
reality is she's not an a-lister and no
one cares about Tigra
and he says even the beyonder is finally
content in this world surrounded by
people who basically adore him and it's
just one of those things where it's like
you America Chavez you could have
everything that you ever wanted you
could have your sister your moms are
alive the utopian parallel is a place
that you can go to you can have a home
he says you can have the life that
you've always wanted don't you feel like
you deserve it and her response isn't
necessarily no to the question of does
she deserve it it's no to do I want to
live in this world and she's like I'll
stick with what I've got now that's
what's so interesting about all this is
because the reality is that for us as
people right for you me anybody else our
life is in some ways kind of governed
and admired by the question what if I
had done this differently right like
what if I had taken a hundred dollars
and invested it in Bitcoin when it was
trading at a fraction of a penny I'd be
I'd be a billionaire right now I'd be
astronomically Rich well maybe not maybe
not with 100 bucks but like you'd have a
lot more money than you have right now
right like what if I had made this
decision regarding college instead of
that decision what if I gone to a trade
school instead of college right what if
I had done this or that or any number of
things I think for us as people it's
natural to look at the decisions that
we've made over the course of our lives
and to wonder what if we had done
something different this conversation
between Gloria and America Chavez and
even the other members of The Defenders
who jump in Tai is showing up and saying
this is the kingdom of never the true
world of couldn't be shouldn't be if
gallon plays big hungry in the cosmos to
come he has a key role in future history
that's the role that he's supposed to
play to fix him up quote unquote would
be to wipe him out and when glorian's
saying things like I would do a reboot
after reboot right I would just reboot
over and over and over again until I got
quote unquote the perfect Universe until
I got it right the response to Taya is
like is that really what it's going to
be us as individuals here or just play
things for you to just kind of rewrite
reality on your whim until you figure
out what it is even blue Marvel says I'd
rather live my own life whether I made
the right choices or not then some cozy
historical fiction this is them sort of
looking at glory and saying like yes we
could kind of have this perfect world as
you created and yes our lives would be
would be rebooted over and over again
but the truth is we are the people that
we are because of the choices that we
made and so it's really kind of
intriguing here because when you have
glory and he says okay fine like nobody
else is going to side with me right find
whatever you guys are going to reject
all this that's cool with the power of
the Beyond or I can draw on that and
everything will be cool if I can get to
be honor to agree with this I can draw
on the beyonder's power and do seemingly
anything that I want to and the funny
thing about to be honor is true you
could I do have unlimited power I could
do virtually anything that I want to I'm
one of the most powerful beings in
existence but the reality is my only
real desire is to understand desire and
seeing the Defenders resist your offers
well that was just simply fascinating
and it makes me want to hear from all
five of them not the four that you've
set free and so he ultimately unleashes
Loki and then brings Loki in now the
funny thing about this is remember Loki
as he exists now is the god of stories
and they're in the land of couldn't be
shouldn't be which means if it's
basically like writing on an empty page
whatever Loki puts there becomes an
absolute truth that's the way this works
his power literally runs the opposite of
glorian's power glorion is imbued by all
the possibilities that can exist but
he's limited to whatever Loki does right
and so literally at that point going
forward Loki gets the eternity mask
right it's literally handed to him by
America Chavez that makes him equal to
glorion at that point he just starts
writing the narrative he's just like
okay cool like let's see what we can do
Loki holding this mask he literally says
oh I get it the mask is a piece of
Eternity substance with a handful of
this glorion really could have made his
dream world real infected eternity from
the inside but unlike certain moldy
golden oldies I think outside the box
and so where he's begged by glorion the
response of Loki is see what I mean DOL
DOL DOL you've got nothing I want
glorian not even a fight being equal to
you is a step down with me wielding this
eternity mask but what else can I use a
little piece of Eternity for maybe to
contact other Cosmic entities who is a
multiversal personification that I've
got on speed dial and this is when he
draws the queen of Nevers now the queen
of Nevers is a ridiculously powerful
Cosmic entity and depending on on who's
writing the story and how you handle it
her power could transcend that of the
Living Tribunal she'd be second to the
one above all and the reason why is
because she represents the sum total of
any and all possibilities the
possibility of the Living Tribunal being
destroyed and never returning the
possibility of the one above all dying
she represents all these different
things and so as a result of that her
power is a reflection of that now again
it's one of these things where it's fast
and loose some of you guys may kind of
draw the conclusion well in that case
she's more powerful than the one above
all I mean no like Marvel does create a
definitive hierarchy the one above all
is called the one above all for a reason
but she says I'm called the queen of
Nevers who is also queen of always that
it's one of those things where it's like
anything that is possible I represent I
represent all these different things and
so literally she whisks The Defenders
away from glorion and brings them
directly to her realm and so that's
where she says that much like eternity
and infinity she exists as a sort of
balance here right that where eternity
represents time and infinity represents
space that the queen of Nevers one part
of her does represent couldn't be
shouldn't be things that should never
happen things that should never take
place and things that can never take
place because they shouldn't take place
but she also represents can be shall be
which means things that can take place
therefore there are things that will
take place right basically the idea is
that Marvel Comics writers have their
mom was approved of I mean if we're
being honest here and we're using meta
textual stuff this Marvel editorial
saying you know what we'll go ahead and
go with that idea that idea resides in
the land of Canby shaldi the idea is
where Marvel's just like no we're never
gonna do that that resides in the land
of couldn't be be right if we're using
Comics as a meta textual kind of
representation of how Marvel does things
that's really how this stuff works but
again what we have here is her talking
about this notion of unchecked
possibility right that unchecked
possibility is definitively freedom even
in your world you'd be surprised at what
can actually happen again it's sort of
this alluing commentary on the fact that
this idea of thinking that your life is
somehow limited right like you have to
work a nine to five because that's the
only way to find success and it's the
only way to retire right that that's
limited thinking I make a living
rambling about comic books for 30
minutes right like don't talk to me
about what can or cannot be done your
ability to achieve things in your life
or in this life especially in this
digital age when everything is
accessible at your fingertips it's
limited only by your imagination right
it's one thing that I would love for you
guys to take away from this is that at
the end of the day your ability to live
your life and the things that you can
achieve in your life is limited by your
imagination the important thing here is
this right that in this conversation
that takes place between like the
Defenders and so on Loki says but how
come you're here instead of back there
in the world that we came from not to be
a downer but I've experienced what's
quote unquote possible there and it
absolutely hurt because Loki was turned
into a tree but she says I'm on my
journey you're on yours and none of us
have the map but she says I can promise
you one thing my cynical Storyteller the
journey never ends not even when we pass
through the final door Defenders the
door to the godhood itself and what she
does is she presents them to the door of
God and says this door here it leads to
the house of ideas now where that leads
to we'll find out in the next video
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with Defenders
Beyond and this is the conclusion and
yes the one above all makes his return
now this story is going to shift up
everything you know about the one above
all and I love the way that it's done
right so in the last video that we did
we basically picked up with kind of the
conclusion of that little bit of a story
that the Defenders were effectively
moving to what was called the house of
ideas now this is a phrase that Al Ewing
is using both in terms of the story but
as well as the real world and the reason
why is because Marvel Comics used to be
called the house of ideas that was kind
of their great big huge tag name and so
with that being the case once Adam
Brashear gets in here and he's met by
the one above all he's basically given
the same line that more or less the one
above all gives most everybody right I
see through many eyes I build with many
hands they are themselves but they are
also me I am all powerful my only weapon
is love the mystery intrigues me I am as
I am I will be what I will be I am the
one above all now to that Adam Brashears
just kind of like I don't think that's
true now that's one of the crazy things
about this is because in response to
that the one above all launches an
attack against them using all these
different monsters now here's the cool
thing about this if you're familiar with
Marvel Comics this is actually Al ewing
using Marvel's publishing history and
then bringing it into the comic book and
the reason why I say that is because
those of you guys who are not really
familiar with the history of Marvel long
before Marvel was Marvel you had timely
Comics timely Comics is where you got
Jack Kirby and Joe Simon who created
like Captain America right Captain
America Comics number one now one
superhero stopped being popular after
World War II timely Comics changed its
name to Atlas Comics and what Atlas
Comics did which is really where Stan
Lee got his start Atlas Comics was
focusing on science fiction monsters
different things like that it wasn't
until the 1960s with really Fantastic
Four number one that Marvel Comics
became the Marvel Comics that we know
and this is so cool because these
monsters you're seeing here these are
the old stories that Marvel published
before superheroes emerge so it's really
one of these things where it's kind of
alewing offering this kind of commentary
and saying like the one above all has
always existed it's always been around
it's been since the beginning of
everything and so these monsters that
it's spewing up are the creatures that
existed before like the Multiverse
exists as it exists now which is why
they're kind of referred to as like the
beast from before or whatever the case
happens to be now the Defenders are able
to get the upper hand on these guys
pretty quickly and for the most part
they're able to kind of take them out
but these beings are pretty powerful and
so in the midst of all this what you do
is you have Adam Brashear who says I
don't believe in any God who tests their
Creations I've been tested enough all of
humanity has but I do believe in a God
who questions us and who asks us to
question them and that's when the one
above all stops and it simply says then
speak if you have understanding and so
this is where things get amazing right
because what Adam Brashear says here
really he says like there's no power
that we can reach above yours you're as
high as we can go that's what defines
you but does that truly make you above
all he says this is only the beginning
of the journey isn't it the beginning of
what you represent and what creates
creation now this is the thing because
his question right or his statement what
creates creation that's where the one
above all responds it says the place
where the world of action ends and the
world of creation begins so for those of
you guys who are unfamiliar the one
above all in Marvel Comics has
historically been the top person right
and different depictions of the one
above all have taken place for example
there was a story with a Fantastic Four
met the one above all and the one above
all was depicted as Jack Kirby there's
been instances where it's been eluded
that the one above all has is basically
Stan Lee there was a point where the one
above all appeared to Peter Parker and
did not look like Stan Lee or Jack Kirby
so the one above all has always been
kind of depicted as just this
exceedingly powerful being and is the
creation or the reason why all things
exist there's even this idea that the
one above all is basically Marvel
publishing right the the kind of
combination of the writers the artists
the editors the editor-in-chief
everybody who decides what gets
published in Marvel but what Adel Ewing
is doing here is he's putting forward
this idea that the cosmic hierarchy as
we've seen it up to this point the
Phoenix Force the beyonder so on and so
forth that's all just the tangible realm
right that's a being out there who's
really powerful and can do some stuff
what the one above all represents is the
entrance into a whole nother level of
hierarchy that exists out there as far
as people who create things right those
individuals who are capable of creation
that when you have someone like the one
above all everybody who exists
throughout the entirety of the Marvel
Multiverse would be powerless in the
face of the one above all because all it
has to do is just wipe them from
existence and there's no conceivable
means of bringing them back unless the
one above all chooses to that's the way
its character always operated but what
Al Ewing is doing is saying the one
above all is just the first in a new
line of just these astronomically
powerful Cosmic beings that exist out
there that are in charge of creating
everything and so it's a really really
awesome concept because this is a level
of power we've never seen before and so
again where you have Adam Brashear
talking with the one above all and
asking what creates creation above
everything even your creators is there a
final guiding hand can there be do you
know one above all the response is the
mystery intrigues me Adam I have my
answers from you what do you wish from
me and so that's when you kind of get
this sort of statement this made right
each one kind of asking for something in
particular Taya wants to know what's
going on with her son right Galactus
becoming the world of hour because
remember she comes from the universe
where Galactus originated before he ever
became Galactus but what the one above
all says here is Taya your son becomes
the Devourer of Worlds right he's born
into your reality as your son your
universe and the Multiverse will
basically end it'll be reborn and he
will be born into the new universe and
even a new Multiverse as Galactus this
is by my design I intended it to be this
way so it's not some kind of grand
Cosmic mistake despite the fact that it
shocked you to learn that your son would
become a person that just eradicates
entire worlds in the new universe it's
just how I wanted things to be and he
says but you cannot return to your
Cosmos with that knowledge now of course
America Chavez asks about her sister Al
yoon's responses you will find her and
more nothing that was made is ever lost
America Chavez Tigra kind of wants to
know what her purpose is and the one
above all is just like you have no real
purpose teeth and so as a result of that
you basically have this really cool
instance where Adam Brashear asked the
question okay the Defenders have a
mission to complete we were charged by
eternity to travel into the cosmos and
to find this Grand Cosmic threat and so
far we found nothing we've only found a
hierarchy of cosmic beings what's this
Grand threat and what the one above all
says and this is this is going to be
mind-boggling insane the one above all
says behold and take what you can
understand the Grail at the end of your
quest is a single glimpse of the Enigma
to come and so what they're looking at
here to the best of their ability to
interpret it is simply just a giant
crown that stretches across all things
that exist and literally Adam Brashear
says as a crown above all things and so
he simply says it's up to us to decode
the cosmic symbolism so basically Al
yuming is just like there is a source of
power that exists out there that is
beyond the one above all but at the end
of the day okay you're gonna have to
wait to find out what it is
because I'm not going to tell you now as
most people are suspecting this is only
the second part in the trilogy that you
have the defender's comic which was
written by Al Ewing this is part two
which is you could argue it is like The
Empire Strikes Back of the defender's
comic terrible analogy I know just go
with me on that but then part three will
be the Return of the Jedi but hopefully
it'll be better than the in the movie
but it'll be like the part three that
kind of wraps everything up but it's one
of those interesting Concepts because in
that moment Loki chimes in and says okay
so here's the thing in our Quest we were
all brought together by basically the
soul of Doctor Strange we were shown a
crown on the tarot cards so this is the
threat that we have to find some way to
defeat But ultimately we have no earthly
clue how to do this we have no earthly
clue how to pull this off and so what
Loki actually reveals is that the coming
together of the Defenders as it exists
while it was orchestrated by Doctor
Strange Loki went along with it because
what Loki seeks to do is to actually
leave that the power of the realm of the
one above all is that because it exists
out there in the space where things are
created it exists outside the Multiverse
Loki seeks to Eve everything walk away
from the Multiverse to Whole Nine Yards
you could make a convincing argument
here that what Loki's saying is he wants
to enter basically into the real world
he wants to leave the world of fiction
and enter into the real world now the
funny thing about this is that what
we're also really giving here is that
while the Defenders don't necessarily
get into a big conversation about it
they're all basically coming to this
realization they're fictional characters
their stories are guaranteed the things
that happen in their lives happen
because they're supposed to because they
were created that way right Adam
Brashear facing off against anti-man
Connor Sims Loki and all his stories
America Chavez and so on and so forth
it's all pre-written it's like when
Deadpool discovered that he was a
fictional character it's just that
they're not killing the entirety of the
Marvel Universe but it's a cool thing
because of course the beyonder seemingly
shows up out of nowhere in the midst of
all this but the idea behind it is that
you do have Loki kind of given this idea
that he could legitimately just leave
it's an opportunity available to him
that he could just walk away he could
leave the Omniverse the Multiverse step
out into the real world but the other
part of this is that annivers here
chimes in with was something that's
known as the bot he saw the vow now I'm
probably butchering the hell out of that
pronunciation I apologize if I am but
the entire idea behind this vow is the
at least as far as the story goes is
that you had somebody named City Garba I
think is how you pronounce that again
I'm terrible when it comes to
pronunciations like that but this person
vowed not to attain buddhahood until all
Hells were emptied because there is no
Enlightenment until all are enlightened
there is no Freedom until all are free
and so the important thing here and this
is what's kind of nuts about this the
kind of stuff Al Ewing's throwing out
here the Revelation by Adam Brashear and
the Defenders that their fictional
characters Loki trying to leave and walk
away right this idea of of a statement
being made directly to Loki that that at
the end of the day he's like reality
wants me in some old shape it wants me
to be what I used to be and the kind of
counter statement being like do you
think that it can God of stories like do
you think it didn't try that kind of
situation this is all moving or all kind
of pointing towards the idea of a
massive paradigm shift in Marvel Comics
that this notion of what they're kicking
off or at least what they're alluding to
is some massive reworking of the
landscape and the reason why I say that
is because all of this puts forward the
idea that the Defenders themselves
accessing the realm of the one above all
learning the fictional history of
characters it can all be changed it can
be Rewritten that they are given a
status quo but they can leave the status
quo they can alter the status quo they
can change what they want their stories
to be it kind of smells like a bit of a
reboot to a degree now I don't know if
that's gonna happen it's probably me
just as a Marvel Comics fan saying like
it's high time you guys reboot we know
that like Jonathan Hickman and Marvel
are working on something massive coming
out in 2023 this year is supposed to
happen in the summer I don't know if
it's going to be a reboot Marvel needs
to reboot Mariah literally just finished
Secret Wars and I asked her doesn't that
story end where it felt like it was
supposed to be a reboot and she's like
yeah do they reboot and I was like nope
and she's like that sucks because it
feels like they were supposed to reboot
like it it's kind of what it feels like
to me but again it may just be me as the
person wanting to Marvel to reboot kind
of feeding my my own desire right but
the important thing is that the beyonder
himself had actually gone along with
this whole thing just to see if he could
that the reality of the beyonder is that
it doesn't want to go back to the second
Cosmos it doesn't want to go back to its
place where it just hangs around and
waits until something pops off with the
celestials and the beyonders have to
step in that it doesn't really give us a
whole lot of expose until like their
mindset regarding Secret Wars The
Avengers The New Avengers run by
Jonathan Hickman the collapse of the
Multiverse but what it does say is its
desire is to literally leave everything
in creation and see what all is out
there to see if it could possibly even
just create his own thing and so what
happens is this realm is basically
destroyed by the beyonder and then it
literally takes off into Parts Unknown
we have no idea where his story goes and
it could very well be the beyonder does
achieve a whole new level of power
whether Beyond or potentially even takes
the power of the one above all which is
just downright scary but the thing about
this is this Al Ewing kind of setting
the seeds for all these different
characters stories going forward right
Loki still has the eternity mask and
while he does end up traveling back to
Earth he goes back to his place what
this means is that with eternity's mask
his power is equal to whoever he faces
off against if he fights the one above
all his power becomes equal to the one
above all that's how the eternity mask
works there's no limit to it and while
you do have Taya who was supposed to go
back to her reality the response of Adam
Brashear is but the one above all didn't
say when all the one above all said is
that you cannot go back to your Universe
with knowledge of what your son becomes
because you may warn your son you may
stop him from becoming Galactus whatever
the case happens to be these things kind
of have to happen because the character
exists therefore the circumstances must
exist for him to exist the way that he
does and so she basically just kind of
lingers around she becomes a part of the
defender she effectively joins the team
but again AL Ewing leaves it open-ended
he's just like yeah I mean they haven't
found like they know it's the crown but
they don't know what it means and they
haven't really found the main enemy
itself it's just kind of a glimpse of
what awaits them so what it looks like
is going into presumably this quote
unquote third part of the defender's
story things are going to be crazy and
we're gonna end up coming across Cosmic
entities with stupid levels of power
that we didn't even know existed but but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end let me know
what you think about this change with
the one above all and I will catch you
all later
peace
[Music]